[Music]
hello
welcome my name is greg braille i'm here
also with keith danikind
and together we're going to talk about
apis and how people use apis to create
connected digital experiences to create
new
lines of business new product areas new
things out of apis and out of all kinds
of technology
we're going to start out with some
examples about how people actually have
used apis to solve real business
problems
then we're going to talk a little bit
about sort of what this means by showing
you a demo of what it means to be a
consumer of an api
then we'll go into some more detail
about the technology and after we do
that we're going to have another demo
which is going to show you how you
actually use
apogee in order to actually create and
manage these api programs and finally
we'll have time at the end for
questions so if you do have questions i
know there's a there's ways in the tool
that you can actually do that while
we're talking
and we'll be getting to those at the end
so don't be surprised if we don't
address them right away
so i wanted to start off by talking
about interesting things that businesses
have done
around the world primarily using apis
and there are some really interesting
aspects here so for instance if we look
at starbucks
they put in their annual report the 13
of their revenue comes through mobile
apps
those mobile apps are not built on
completely new technology infrastructure
that never existed before because
starbucks has a big infrastructure
already
instead what they did is they used apis
and the mobile apps talk to apis
and the apis then give the mobile apps
just what they need to give a really
good user experience to those apps based
on starbucks
existing technology um other examples
for instance are swisscom which is
actually been offering
apis as a service for some of their
network infrastructure in switzerland or
arity which is part of the insurance
business it used to be in order to bring
a business partner on board they would
have a three to four month process
of negotiation emailing you know
microsoft word docs all that kind of fun
stuff
now with apis they allow their business
partners to get on board with their
business-to-business services within a
few days
completely within self-service and we'll
talk a little bit more about why that's
important
and why that's a big part of everyone's
api programs
the way people use apis and use api
management because this talk is also
going to be a lot about api management
and what it means
is we've been doing this for a while
i've been part of apogee since 2007
we weren't talking about apis back then
but we started soon after
and a lot of customers who come into
this world of apis and api management
they start off with sort of a
point-to-point problem like
my goodness we need to launch an app for
iphone and android
and we don't have any technology in our
existing system that can actually talk
over the internet to those devices how
am i actually going to connect
these mobile devices and all these kinds
of things to
my legacy systems and that's where we
started to see
you know five or six years ago people
doing basic web apis with api management
using api keys in order to protect
access
to an existing service implementing
things like oauth putting things like
quotas in place in order to protect
access to the internet but where things
have gotten really more interesting
recently and the companies that have had
the most interesting successes with apis
are people who are creating
differentiating digital experiences that
is people are creating new ways of doing
business
not only through mobile apps but through
things like digital assistance which we
see all over the place nowadays
and the real fun comes when people are
able to actually transform their
business models and create new
ecosystems and turn their companies into
platforms that other people can do
business on
and i'm going to talk about a few
examples of those
a great example here is magalu if you're
not familiar they actually used to be
called magazine louisa
they're the largest retailer in brazil
and they have been a brick and mortar
retailer for a very long time
and what they've done over the last few
years if they started to change
into more of a platform that third
parties use
to do commerce in brazil they obviously
have a huge infrastructure
they have a huge physical infrastructure
and they started off with that
basic task of creating new digital
experiences hey we need mobile apps we
want to be able to offer e-commerce
but it quickly pivoted into actually now
they have
about well about 100 apis but they have
thousands of partners and suppliers
who use their platform to do things like
sell products using their infrastructure
ship using their supply chain very much
like amazon in the us became
not just an online store but a platform
for e-commerce that thousands and
probably even more producers and
consumers use to transact business
magalu is doing the same thing in brazil
they're sort of becoming the the amazon
of brazil
which is ironic because brazil already
had one of those but but now they have a
digital one too
another great example is accuweather
everyone knows accuweather because you
know some of us still watch tv sometimes
and our
weather information also of our weather
information on our various mobile apps
and things and on the web
comes from accuweather they have a
well-deserved reputation for giving
excellent weather forecasts
they process about 50 billion api
requests a day
and the vast majority of them are from
the weather app on your phone or your
watch or your
refrigerator or whatever right but what
accuweather also does is they have some
high volume forecast products because
long-term weather forecasting is very
important in a lot of industries you
know financial services you know oil and
gas
agriculture these depend greatly on
long-term
very accurate weather forecasts that's
what accuweather is known for
and those forecast products are pretty
valuable so accuweather has whole tiers
of apis
and they have ways in order to bring
business partners on board with those
higher value apis to actually
charge them the value of that
interesting data that they're giving
them
and also to keep track of who's using
the api
and one more example is ticket master we
all know ticketmaster because that's
where you go when you want to buy a
ticket
they of course have a mobile app and a
website and all those kinds of things
but they also one thing that not
everyone knows is ticketmaster
actually offers apis that allow third
parties
to transact business and to buy tickets
on ticketmaster
and in 2016 actually which was a little
while back but ten percent of their
ticket sales came from those partners
and some of those partners are things
like costco hey buy tickets at costco
but there are other aspects where people
have integrated ticketmaster into apps
so for instance you know you just bought
plane tickets somewhere would you like
to buy tickets you bought plane tickets
to new york do you want to go see harry
potter and the cursed child while you're
there um a travel app for a travel site
for instance can now use the
ticketmaster api to integrate that
directly into their app without jumping
out to a completely different digital
experience
so what kind of holds all these together
is that all these various companies are
not only using apis to solve business
problems
but they're not looking apis purely as a
bit of technology
they're looking at the at the api as
something that is for a customer
they're looking at it as a product and i
think that's where things get really
interesting
and that's where apis get really
successful is when you don't just think
of it as
how are we going to get the technology
to get the json to the mainframe that's
going to look at the xml and talk to the
sap
but how are we actually going to create
something that
developers are going to want to use so
for instance magalu deals with retail
partners
so they're api product managers and big
successful apis have product managers
have to think about questions like what
kind of technology do these retailers
use what data formats can they handle
how are they connected to the internet
you know what sort of things do they
need to do
in order to actually access these apis
similarly accuweather ticketmaster
and we all you know we've all been there
most of us are developers or we've
developed software and we know what we
like and we don't like
and what i've always said about
developers for a long time is that
developers aren't lazy but developers
are in a hurry
and they have a very very fast way of
telling by looking at something is this
something i want to engage with
is this something i want to spend my
time on or is this something that's
completely off in a different direction
and is going to be a waste of time or is
going to have to
require me to pull in a bunch of
technology that i don't actually need
the great thing about apis is that it
was based on a very very simple
technology base of http
json oauth tls technologies that are
already prevalent anywhere
so that a developer who wants to learn
to do an api doesn't need to
install a giant tech stack that can
actually get started right away
using technology they probably already
know so what we've seen between projects
and products is that it's really about
even looking at things like you know
what is your revenue what is your csat
for your api what are your lead
generation capabilities you know
is there someone who's looking every
week cat how many people have signed up
to use the api
how has api traffic changed over time
have new people started to come on board
have people who have been customers
before stopped using the api there are a
lot of interesting things that have to
happen there it's just like running any
other digital product
and with that said we're actually going
to start with a demo of
what it looks like to be a consumer of
an api what does it look like to
discover an api
look at the documentation for the api
sign up the api and get started
so keith is going to show us his demo
system right now
thanks greg okay so for the demo we're
going to look at this from three
different perspectives
the application developer the api
developer and the api team
so the application developer or api
consumer
might be saying things like all i want
to do is build an application make it
easy for me to consume your services
the api developer who's taking services
and packaging them up so that
application developer can use them
that person might be saying i need to
share a service with other people but
there's some limits we have to control
what they can do
the api team who's running the api
program they may be saying something
like
i want to think about apis as software
products there's customers there's life
cycles there's versions
i want to measure my program and i want
to tune it so in this case i'm going to
play the role of the application
developer or api consumer
and in this case one of our suppliers
has a large erp system
and we place orders with them and we'd
like to check on the status of those
orders and this is a somewhat time
consuming process right now
they've granted us an api to be able to
go speed up that process and automate
this and to integrate that information
into our internal tracking applications
so let's see what it looks like to use
the order management and order tracking
apis
so here's their developer portal and
what i want to learn about is how to
track the status of an order if i have
an order number
so let's see what they have here get
started get a key and test out the apis
learn about and try our apis so well how
do you get started
get started in three steps sign in
register apps access the api keys
okay that sounds easy enough let's see
what the apis are
looks like there is a order status
tracker here
and someone's written some nice
documentation to make this easy for me
so i call a url i put an order number at
the end of there
i'm going to need to supply an api key
and an order number
and i should be able to make this work
i'll get back some data that looks like
this so that's pretty good
i have a reasonable idea of how this
might work i'm going to go register for
an api key
and i'm going to test this out
so i come over to here and i'm going to
click on apps
i'm going to register a new application
and we'll use this order tracking api
when i create this it'll register my
application and it'll give me
an api key so now that we have that key
let's go back to the documentation
and try it out
i'll put the key in there we'll grab a
sample order number
and there we go that's what the results
look like so i see the data is in here
and that's what i would expect to be
returned when i call this api
easy enough to do let's build an
application
so here's a simple order status tracking
application
you put an order number in here press
search
and we get back some status of this
order so we get all the details there
very easy to write this took me about 15
minutes or so and
best thing was i didn't need to have any
knowledge of what's on the back end
system
how this order system on the other end
works i just had a simple api to call
and it returned that data
i built a single page web application
and put it in here it'd be easy to embed
this in any kind of application
so that's the demo from the perspective
of the api consumer or application
developer
next let's look at this from the api
product manager's point of view
what is it like to manage this api
program
so let's see how our api program is
running
to do that i'm logged into the apigee
experience
i'm going to come over and click on the
analyze button and from there i see a
bunch of different reports i can look at
let's look at a few of these and see we
can find out about how the api program
is running
this first report shows us proxy
performance and we can see how much
traffic we've gotten in the last hour or
so
and we'll see a few people who looks
like they're probably getting rate
limited
we see average response time in here we
see traffic by proxy and average
response time by proxy so this is a good
overall operational metric just telling
us how our api program is running
so this report shows developer
engagement what we're seeing in here is
there's a total of 10 developers
seven of them have apps four are active
and we've got one that's highly active
so this gives us an idea of how engaged
our developers are
we can see which devices people are
using this might influence
how we support different clients and
things like that so we can see who's on
mobile who's on desktop
and then what kind of browsers they're
using
the geo map shows us where people are
calling from so if we click in and zoom
in on the united states here
we can see that there's a lot of traffic
from california and some is coming from
colorado
this is a custom report that shows us
order status format so
this api will return data in xml format
or
json format depending on what type of
accept header you send so if you put
application json as the accept type
it'll return json data
if you put application xml on the header
it'll return xml data and that was to
support some older clients
it's interesting from the company's
point of view to see how people are
using this
the xml interface is a legacy interface
and we want to see who's still using
that so this gives us an idea over time
of
uh who's calling what and what they're
doing with it so we get an idea of what
kind of responses people are interested
in
and we could look at that trend over
time and it'll show us
we can compare that to a previous period
so look at let's look at the previous
hour versus this hour we can compare the
two periods
so you can build custom reports in
apogee to do anything you want you can
grab data that apogee stores and you can
grab anything out of the request or
response build your own custom report
for that
so using these analytics reports
building your own custom reports gives
you some good insights into how your api
program is running
okay thanks so what keith showed you was
not only what does an api
look like as the consumer of an api but
what does the api product manager
actually do how does that api product
manager keep track of who's using the
api
and control that so now i want to talk a
little bit about the technology under
the covers and what are some of the
technical considerations you have to put
into place
if you want to successfully offer an api
for lots and lots of people
so it all starts with digital consumer
management or really the management of
who's consuming your api
you could just call this api management
and what we find
in the industry is that a lot of people
know the terms api management and a lot
of people know the terms api gateway
and they use them interchangeably and
actually when we talk about api
management
we're talking about this thing here that
apigee has
used many times in the past that we call
the digital value chain but the really
important thing about this from our
perspective
is that this is about managing the
relationship between the api producers
over there on the right who are creating
that api those product managers
architects engineers who have created
the api and then over to the left the
api consumer that's the actual developer
who is building an app otherwise known
as a digital experience that's going to
use that api
so api consumer management is all about
managing that relationship
so what keith showed you in the demo was
he showed you both the
api consumer side of that relationship
as well as the api producer side what
does it mean to actually be a person who
manages an api
and then later on in the next demo we'll
get into the details of how do the api
consumers actually use an api management
product to make all of those things
happen
i'll talk about a few other technologies
that are really really important here as
well
one of them is oauth oauth is i know
we're jumping into technology all of a
sudden and
this might seem a little abrupt but this
is a really important part of api
management because what's happened in
the industry
over the last six or seven years is that
oauth has become the standard for api
authentication it's not just a de facto
standard
it's an actual set of ietf standards
which makes it a real standard then it's
used by almost everybody whenever you
are using google or facebook or twitter
or maybe not amazon but almost
everything out there
whenever you get to one of those pages
that says sign in or
anytime you do sign in with google sign
in with facebook sign in with github
you're using oauth oauth was originally
designed
to solve a browser single sign-on
problem but oauth since then has
actually been used very
often for mobile authentication and for
authentication of all kinds of devices
and the reason it's important
is because at the end of the whole oauth
process what the device
ends up with is a token which is a bit
of
stuff that may have some structure to it
or might just be a set of random numbers
that some sort of gateway which i have
down here on the bottom an api gateway
needs to actually authenticate and
decide whether or not to allow access to
the api
and then how that token is produced can
now vary
depending on the business requirements
so for instance it can be as simple as
popping open a form where you type in
your username and password
or it could involve two-factor
authentication physical security tokens
consent screens those screens we all
know and love that say hey do you give
application x the permission to see your
email address
and look at all of your friends that's
all the oauth protocol
and related specs like open id connect
make all of that stuff happen
the important part about this is that we
have a couple of parts of oauth that are
there
one of them is the api gateway which
actually enforces you have to have a
proper token in order to access these
services
another is what's called the
authorization server products like
apigee can act as an authorization
server but so can many others
and then api management is a really
important part of oauth because what
technologists don't understand
right away is that oauth is not only end
user authentication
it's greg using my api it's also
application authentication
greg is making an api call from version
7
of the iphone app for the package
tracking api
then for the api product named package
tracker that allows the api product
manager to know who's using the api
and it allows the people responsible for
security to know things like you know
an app popped up on that we didn't know
about that's creating a lot of traffic
or we accidentally pushed out a bad
release of the app it's got a problem
you have to take all the api calls from
that app and wrap them and send them off
somewhere else or
you know worst case scenario a developer
signed up for the api
they're using the api in a way that's
inconsistent with our terms of service
we have to stop that application from
using our api right away
these are all things that happen a lot
in the world of api management and
they're possible because the oauth
authorization server is very tightly
coupled with the api management system
another thing happens a lot on apis is
the idea of a quota
quotas are you know were part of the
very first public web apis and they
exist because
if you're going to let people you don't
trust use your api
you have to have some way to control how
much they use it otherwise they can
cause big big production problems for
you
you don't want to be in a situation
where someone signed up for your api
and if you have no oauth you might not
know what application is using the api
but even if you do without a quota you
don't want them to drive
api usage to such a point that it
produces denial of service for your
other customers
now there's a whole range of traffic
management strategies you have to put in
place when you put an api on the
internet ddos for instance the kind of
classic
tcp distributed denial service attacks
that we all have heard about
from botnets those actually to a certain
degree have to be handled at the network
level
at the ip level and you know the big
cloud providers for instance have
sophisticated technology for this
as anyone who runs a lot of volume on
the internet similarly we have to have
things like
rate limits in in routers and gateways
that control you know hey this bit of
technology
really is going to fall apart if it
handles more than 10 000 concurrent
requests
the quota is more of a business limit it
controls which application is allowed to
use the api
and how much without a quota you can't
really have self-service you can't let
just anyone sign up for your api
if you can't control how much they use
it and it's not only because people
might do nefarious things
but also because you need to protect
against people making dumb mistakes
you know hey someone accidentally pushed
out a version of the api
uh whenever it sees an error it retries
immediately with no delay
great you know if you have a quota at
least you can protect yourself from that
kind of api from that sort of bad access
pattern
similarly quota also makes it possible
to have business relationships to have
different tiers of service
keith's api for instance he might want
to say that
you know for free you get a very low
quota but if you're a giant website and
you're going to be driving thousands of
requests a second to the api
you need a quota so that we can control
how much you use it
apis also face all kinds of interesting
security threats
many of these are things that are
familiar to you if you've done anything
else on the web
but there are some things that you know
might be a little bit unique to apis we
need to think about
so for instance um if you're opening an
api
up to third party and you're letting
your third party post json or xml or
anything else to you
you're basically letting anyone who can
sign up on the internet send arbitrary
content to your server
now depending on what technology you
have behind it and what the format is
that data that can be sent to your
server could contain all kinds of things
in theory it could contain things like
viruses but more likely someone might
try to do something like send you a json
knock document that's nested a million
levels deep
or send you a json document with a
string in it that's 100 megabytes long
and these kinds of things could actually
cause problems to your back ends
depending on what kind of technology
stack they implement and
how robust they are api gateways like
apogee do have efficient ways
to reject those kinds of things before
they get in there's other things too you
know things like sql injection things
like
google has a service called data loss
prevention which can look at the
responses to your api calls and make
sure that you're not inadvertently
sending out people's
social security numbers or credit card
numbers or things like that
so there's a whole lot of threats that
apis face some of which are specific to
apis and that we want to make sure we
address in the api tier as well
and one more thing that comes up it's
not necessary for every api but it
becomes very important in the world of
apis
is the concept of mediation and
transformation and this is where so many
companies we started
out earlier on with a slide where we
showed that people progressed from a
simple point-to-point integration
scenario
to something that was more sophisticated
where they're building a new platform
but almost everyone who starts out in
the world of apis has some sort of
technology already and if you're in the
kind of shop where you can rewrite
everything and you can make changes and
you have enough flexibility in your tech
stack
that's awesome you could do whatever you
need when you need to do it
but people who have built up their
businesses over a period of years
typically don't always have that kind of
flexibility everywhere on their tech
stack
so it can sometimes be very important to
be able to layer an api
in front of other services and those
services may vary
and how close they are to the api you
actually want to offer
many businesses have mainframes and
those mainframes aren't going away
anytime soon
sisters have sap salesforce they have
soap web services that were built in the
heyday of the soap era
they have node.js apps that might speak
very very well structured
beautifully structured apis in json it
might just be a mess
the api gateway is often used in order
to sort of mediate those legacy systems
and transform things transform json into
xml
transform json into grpc um transform
json
into a format that might be easier to
parse for the app an api gateway can
perform a very important use case there
another thing that api gateways do which
is actually even more common
is they act as a virtualization layer so
if i look on my lower right hand corner
there we have a collection of
microservices
and if you're doing microservices the
way that you know people who are really
into microservices want to do
the whole idea is that that collection
of microservices could have
five microservices or 50 microservices
or 5000 microservices
and it really shouldn't matter to the
consumer of the api how that's done
the whole point of microservices is that
the teams that own those services are
free to rearrange them
and change them and implement them on
the technology base they want and they
should be able to do that without
everyone knowing about it so it would be
a big disaster if your system made the
50 microservices was structured in such
a way that all of your customers api
clients had to change
when you wanted to split that into now
100 different microservices
so one very important things api
gateways do in microservices
architecture is they act as a
virtualization point
they present a consistent interface a
set of http
uris and verbs uri patterns and verbs
more specifically
that are consistent and stable and well
documented
and presented to that end user
application and then that api gateway
behind the covers can change
as the actual technology implementation
changes
maybe as legacy systems are replaced
with real systems or new systems in
addition and when microservices or
environments are refactored
that api gateway can also act as that
virtualization layer
and with that said i want to talk
quickly about google's api management
and api
gateway products they're going to get
into one more demo
google in the world of apis if you go to
the google cloud console you'll actually
see that we have
two major product families um right now
we have a product called cloud endpoints
cloud endpoints is an api
gateway and it's only an api gateway uh
the advantage of cloud endpoints is that
it's small
it's cheap and it's it's very well
suited for applications where you have
very basic needs for an api gateway that
you can deploy quickly especially to
google cloud although cloud endpoints
will run anywhere
uh cloud endpoints can interact with
some of the other api
infrastructure already built into google
cloud so you can authenticate an api
call with an api key for instance
or you can use a service account token
which if you've worked with gcp you're
very familiar with and it's great for
those use cases
we also have apogee and keith and i
spent most of our time on apigee
apigee is a full lifecycle api
management product it's not only a
gateway that can do the various symbol
gateway things that endpoints can do
as well as a more sophisticated gateway
that can even do some of the
transformation and mediation things i
talked about
it's also got attached with it a whole
api management
platform that allows api product
managers and others to keep track of
what api products they've created
tie them to documentation control who's
actually allowed to use those products
what they're allowed to do
set individual quotas for different
consumers use roles based access control
to control what kind of consumers can
see which apis which api calls they can
make what talks they can see
it's all the real designed for the
complete enterprise life cycle
of an api program and that is i think in
my opinion equally relevant
if you're offering an api on the
internet to third-party developers
as it is if you're a large or even
medium-sized organization
that wants to offer internal apis that
are consumed by lots of different teams
and this is actually a picture of that
platform we talk about some of the
components of the platform including
developer portals which are sort of the
key
user facing presence for your api
as well as some of the interesting
analytics we give that we showed you
earlier in the demo
as well as a lot of services including
transformation security
orchestration and those kinds of things
one other thing i will mention about
apogee
is that apogee actually has a couple
different deployment options this is a
very frequently asked question
so we like to talk about it in the
beginning the apogee edge platform
runs as software as a service as part of
google cloud which means that the api
gateway
runs inside google cloud it can sit in
between clients and servers really
anywhere
and the whole api management platform is
run by google cloud
however we offer other options as well
for instance there is a hybrid option
in which you're allowed to have parts of
the apogee gateway running in your data
center with the rest of apogee running
in cloud
and there's an on-premises option where
everything runs
in your own space managed by you and
that can mean your own physical data
center
your own amazon web services account
your own google cloud account
your own azure account and we've had
customers do all of those kinds of
things
so with that said we're actually going
to go back to the very last demo
keith is going to show us some of the
details of apogee and how to use it to
actually add api management to an
existing service
so we saw how people called the api and
we saw how people manage the api program
and how they build programs and things
like that but how do we get the service
up and running what did we do
in apigee to make this work so the order
service is a cloud function that's
running in google cloud
in order to use it you've got to send in
an authorization header and the
credentials for that are stored inside
of apigee
on the left hand side of this there's a
single page web application that you saw
it has an api key that was generated by
apigee and there's a few more mobile
applications all of them have their own
api key
that's that lets me track who's calling
and it does something else
there's a few fields that show up if
you're using an internal api key that
don't show up if you're using an
external api key
and the idea is people inside the
company might need to know who the sales
team was that fulfilled this order but
that's not something you want to share
with the outside people
so when this runs through apigee if
you're using a particular api key we'll
remove that information
and that gives the right information to
the right people so one url
for everybody and different api products
to manage who can see what
so the idea was we want to build a
facade in the back end the fact that
this is a cloud function or what's
running back there
really isn't that important to the
experience we want to control access to
some features
so some of that data we might want to
remove and they only get a small
portion of what might be available
through a real order tracking system or
through a whole erp system back there
i'm going to put some rate limits on
there so that people don't call this
excessively and impose some quotas you
know internal people can call it a
certain number of times and external
people also have their own quotas
we want to add caching so i put a five
minute cache on here somebody checks the
order again and again it'll just grab
that from memory
and there's a five minute time to live
on that cache i wanted to reformat the
request in the response a little bit
it's mostly good but i want to remove a
few fields in there
so those are different things you might
do with apogee in a situation like this
so let's look into what i built in here
so when i went to build the api
i started off with an existing service
so this is just a cloud function that i
can call
and we'll take a look at what it returns
so we hit the url we put the order
number on the end of there
and we get back some basic data in here
that shows us
about the order so that's nice and i
wanted to control access to this
through apogee and i also wanted to
remove this sales group field
depending on whether you're internal or
external and i also wanted to support
xml
the internal service returns json but
some external consumers are still using
xml and they wanted to get data in xml
format
so here's the api and this is what it
would look like if we consumed it
through
apogee so what we'll notice in here
is that that field has disappeared and
we can request
xml or json so in this case it's json
but if i send a different header in
there
we get back xml there it is formatted so
same data
but an x but an xml format and that's
going to support clients who are
currently
living in the xml world so other things
we can do with this
i've got two different api keys i'm
sending api key as a url parameter and
depending on which one i use i get back
an extra field
so this is the api key that's intended
for external people
and then if i switch to this other api
key and make the call again
we'll notice that sales group shows up
and that was the field that i wanted to
hide from outside people
so you can hand out different api keys
and this is personalized it's going to
give the right response to the right
person
and i'll show how i did that in apigee
so that's the data that comes back let's
look at
the actual api and what i had to do to
turn this regular service into something
that i could manage with apigee
so let's look at the api proxy that i
built to make this happen
so i've logged into the apigee
experience and i'm going to play the
role of
api developer so i have that existing
service i want to manage access to it
using apigee
so i came over to api proxies
from here you can create a new proxy but
what we're going to do is we'll look at
this
border status proxy and see what's in
there
so there's the back end url and there's
the url in apigee that we're going to
call so we call apigee
it manages this connection the request
and response flow and it's going to send
it on to here and then we'll get the
response
back so we'll click over here on develop
and we'll see within our flow we've got
a few different steps so these different
policies do different things
you can configure them to do things
there's a whole palette of them right
over here
so let's look at what i've added i've
added a verify api key check
so i'm going to look in the request for
a query parameter called api key
and that's what i'm going to check for
api keys if we don't send one we're
going to get back an unauthorized error
spike arrest is going to limit this to
100 calls per minute you can set that to
whatever you'd like and that's just to
protect our back end
and then we saw in the report that i was
able to tell whether somebody was
requesting xml data or json data
i did that with this statistics
collector i'm grabbing the accept header
and i'm recording that as request type
and then i can put that in my custom
report
i've got a response cache in here and
the response cache has a
300 second time to live and then the key
has two different fragments to it so i
wanted to do it off of the uri
and that worked quite well but then i
figured out that i was caching the wrong
type of data for the wrong type of
person so
it's possible that people send in the
same url but one of them gets xml back
and one of them gets json back
so we also have to look at the accept
type in the header to make sure we send
back the right response and it gets
cached correctly
the backend system requires an
authorization header i've got the
secrets for that stored in a key value
map inside of apigee
so what this will do is it'll go grab
the order status authentication code
from the key value map and store it in a
variable
and then we set that as an authorization
header that we're going to send to the
back end
and that lets us in on the way back
we're going to conditionally remove the
sales group and i've got some javascript
in there to do that
so this makes a reference to remove
salesgroup.js
and right down here three lines of
javascript very simple
so we're going to grab the response
and turn it into an object in javascript
and then we're just going to delete the
field
sales group and then we're going to take
that object and turn it back into a
string
and then we're going to replace the
outgoing response content with that new
improved response
after that this will get called
conditionally so based on whether
they've
had that header or not we'll convert it
to xml or we won't
and then we've got core support in here
so that we can call this from the
browser
so that's our basic api proxy wasn't too
bad to build
okay let's do some questions someone
said restricting application
to certain apis so there's actually
multiple
multiple levels of which you might want
access control right if you're using
for instance oauth to protect access to
an api
then to a certain degree it's up to what
user authentication system is behind
your oauth as to what end users can use
your api
but the thing that apigee and any api
management tool gives you is the ability
to control
what applications can use your api and
which developers can build an
application so you can
set controls on who was allowed to build
an application
for a specific api you can even set
controls in apogee on for instance who's
allowed
to see documentation for apis or to find
out which apis exist
um there are a lot of a lot of things in
there based on things reflect by that
right we always got the latency question
and the answer is it depends um when
apogee runs as a service
the the actual proxy runs in a google
cloud data center
we have a lot of those they also happen
to be very very close to amazon data
centers and very well connected
so if your target is
in the same region or very close or in
the same geographical area
then it depends on what you do with the
policies but it's
you know no more than a few milliseconds
plus network latency if your data center
is you know on an aircraft carrier in
the south pacific being connected by
satellite
then it's going to add a lot of latency
sure and yeah
so the when i was writing um just as an
example this demo
i had a cloud function running on the
back end and i was seeing
about 300 millisecond response time and
that was just network
between me and the data center and i saw
that cut in half once i added caching to
it so if you had caching you may find
that the performance can be drastically
increased because we don't have to talk
to the back end at all
so a few strategies to deal with that
exactly someone asked about cloud
endpoints
i should actually talk about that and
that's a big part of my life um cloud
endpoints in apigee today
do different things for different
customers so for instance cloud
endpoints is very handy for
sharing an api with other google cloud
users
and you know runs at a low cost is easy
to set up
does a fairly limited number of things
apogee is a full featured api management
product with a whole bunch of complex
enterprise features like we've been
talking about now
over time you know both cloud endpoints
and apigee come from the same company
and the same group of people so over
time we're going to make those things
work together more seamlessly um exactly
what's going to happen and when
is not something i can talk about right
now but if you are if you are using
cloud endpoints we'd actually love to
hear from you as well
because we're you know trying to get
some customer feedback again
right now they serve different purposes
for different kinds of users and we want
to make sure that we respect all that
thanks greg there's a question here the
person is asking we worked in the past
with a two layer model where we had an
api gateway
on the edge communicating to an internal
api gateway that did mediation
com composition and so on uh where's
apigee finish this so is apogee is it
okay to put these two
things together so you could certainly
use apogee as a simple gateway on the
outside it can also do a lot of this
mediation stuff so you saw
when i use the javascript policy in the
demo in there to change the request to
response do dynamic routing
a lot of that can be done in apigee and
it's really an architectural choice
about where you do that
and and how that fits into your
organization people like that they can
quickly build things in apogee i would
say
if you've got full-blown business logic
that's that's long-running and
complicated
put that behind apogee if you've got
something that's going to be stateless
and dynamic that's related to returning
the right format or something like that
that's great to do an apogee was asking
about baseline security controls do you
have baseline security controls
developed for apigee envious vsi and
kubernetes i don't know what vsi is
but i will say that we have a security
reporting thing that we're working on
and i don't actually know i think it's
alpha
yeah it'll do a report on but but i mean
what you've implemented in terms of your
use of apogee if you're a customer we'd
love to talk to you more about that
because we're looking at
basically how do we tell you as an
apogee customer you know hey you have
security policies about use of tls and
things like that and you're not
following them in this particular api
proxy and
you can use that to help make sure those
things are being enforced great thanks
so that's all the time we've got for
questions today i want to remind you
that
speaking of security there's a gartner
report in the resources tab and it's
entitled how to build an effective
api security strategy and you can
download that through the resources
window or on your screen
thank you so much for attending today
we'll see on the next webcast
you